with Disney recently buying Fox many
fans were unsure about what would happen
to the all-time favorite Wade Wilson
alias Deadpool whose rats now belong
entirely to Disney after all the last
two Deadpool films all had an R rating
in such films will drag strongly on the
image of the company that became famous
for children's movies - the joy of all
fans Disney boss Alan horn announced at
comic-con that we can expect more from
that fool in the future Oran didn't want
to tell us more but we are curious what
Disney will be doing with the Deadpool
franchise in the future none other than
Star Wars icon and Luke Skywalker actor
Mark Hamill will dub the vicious killer
doll in Chucky's remake on twitter he
published a short video that shows him
how he will present Chucky in child's
play however the story of the remake
will be different than in the original
instead of an obsession by the serial
killer Charles Lee ray or briefly called
Chucky and the new part a malfunction of
a toy will lead the doll to develop
murderous intentions
this time it is even equipped with
artificial intelligence and does not
come from a dark cellar laboratory but
from a worldwide operating company Mark
Hamill will be joined by his colleagues
Oprah Plaza
Gabriel Bateman and Tim Matheson both
original producer David Kirchner and the
creator of the original film Don Mancini
won't have anything to do with the
remake the cinema released for all fans
of the new killer dog will be on June
21st 2019 we have some news from the
Suicide Squad franchise Jai Courtney
more commonly known as Captain Boomerang
will return to Suicide Squad in the
second part being the first returnee to
be officially confirmed after it was
announced at the end of February that
Will Smith will not return as Deadshot
these are positive news for all Suicide
Squad fans in an interview with The
Business Insider Courtney reveals among
other things that preparations for the
shoot are already in progress in a few
month and that unfortunately he can't
reveal much more he only lets it shine
through that the zoo says what will
certainly be different but still great
whether margot robbie will return as
Harley Quinn or Jared Leto as Joker in
the near future is more than
questionable
apparently director James Gunn will go
without both of them however in view of
the sued shooting started very likely
that more details about the cast will be
revealed in the near future by the way
the official started will probably be
August 6 2021 it seems that there
currently are two drummers that always
win at the box office
superhero movies and horror films
currently Shazam is expected to make
between 45 and 50 million u.s. dollars
on his debut she's Emma's about teenager
Billy bests and who can transform in a
superhero when he says the magic word
the film is said to be funny as he
doesn't take himself too seriously
varieties opined Lieberman said you've
got to giggle at this stuff that's part
of the adventure
if Shazam will be as successful as
expected it will be the third success
story in a row for DC entertainment as
the studio attempts to fashion an
alternative to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
when advantage of Shazam is that it
doesn't have to pull the same kind of
ticket sales like Aquaman or Wonder
Woman which were twice as expensive to
produce Warner Brothers position Shazam
well between the slew of superhero
titles arriving in theaters this year as
it's arriving over a month after this
news Captain Marvel and a few weeks
ahead of Avengers and Cape after the
first season of Umbrella Academy Ross
released on Netflix in February this
year it is now confirmed that Netflix
has ordered a second season of the
somewhat different superhero series on
Instagram the screaming giant released a
small video clip which confirms that a
second season is planned the shooting is
scheduled to start in Toronto this
summer season one is about seven
superhero children all born mysteriously
on the same day next to 36 other babies
and adopted by a certain Sir Reginald
Hogg reefs they all have different
superpowers and are prepared at Umbrella
Academy to save the world fans of the
first season will also be able to enjoy
the same cast as Ellen Page Tom Harper
Emma raver Lampman
David Cassidy ADA Robert Sheehan Aidan
Gallagher and Justin min will all return
executive producer Steve Blackman will
also be back behind the camera again
nothing is known about the release of
the second season yet but you can expect
it to be released next year
many fans of the avatar series may have
been surprised to see windy is not
Instagram alongside James Cameron on the
Avatar set will the Fast and Furious
star play a role in one of the plant
sequels probably not since the video
with Cameron's comments looks more like
these lists just visiting this set
even his statement that he always wanted
to work with Cameron shouldn't be put
too much weight on meanwhile Cameron
joke said if he talks too much about the
shoot he'll has to erase his mind this
all clearly just seems like a short
wizard on set yet many fans probably
have hoped that when diesel will play a
role in the Avatar movies avatars
release date is December 18th 2020 while
its successor avatar 3 is scheduled for
December 17th 2021
[Music]